Can someone track down the women
Kamala Harris says are bleeding out in parking lots
because Roe v. Wade was overturn?
Yeah, they're right here.
Amber Thurman needed a DNC
after abortion
medication didn't completely dispel the remains of her pregnancy.
Georgia's new abortion law made doctors hesitate,
fearing prosecution. 20 hours of delay,
the infection spread. Amber died.
Candy Miller, a mother of three from Georgia,
faced an unintended pregnancy in 2022.
Due to Georgia's abortion ban,
she couldn't get the care she needed.
Despite her life threatening conditions,
she attempted to end the pregnancy herself,
leading to severe complications.
And these are just a couple of stories.
This is the reality in America today.
No one deserves to be left in a parking lot bleeding
simply because they needed an abortion and reproductive care.
And I'm sure that you, regardless of your political affiliation,
agree to. I believe in a future where medical care is a right,
but we need to show up for it.
Vote for repro rights November 5th.